- You ready?
- Yeah.
- [rapping] Now here's a little story
that I got to tell
about three bad brothers
that you know so well.
It started way back
in history
- with Ad-Rock--
- MCA--
- And me, Mike D.
[cheering]
- Hello, everyone.
- What we're gonna do
right here is go back.
Way back.
Back into time.
-WOMAN: The Beastie Boys.
-MAN 1: The Beastie Boys.
-MAN 2: The Beastie Boys.
-MAN 3: The Beastie Boys.
- In the early '80s, everyone
in our scene was in a band.
We wanted to be rappers so bad.
But we were mediocre at best.
- [rapping] Now hit it, hop,
just don't stop....
- Most rappers hold their rhymes
in little pieces of paper, right?
- We went from being famous
in a 14 block radius
to being on tour with
Madonna and Rick Rubin.
- The shows kept getting
bigger and bigger.
- We morphed from
making fun of party bros
to actually becoming
those dudes.
- We were burning out.
- I just didn't even recognize the person
that I had become at that point.
- Yo, hold up!
It's not over yet.
- Go!
- There's not that many times
in your life
when you realize
you're in a new chapter.
- WOMAN: The Beastie Boys are back
after a six year absence.
- We changed how we
wanted to be
as people and friends.
- We got inspired,
and while experimenting,
we found our voice.
- Woo!
- Really? High five?
- Yeah. Yeah, it's comin' back, Adam.
It's comin' back.
- Adam Yauch was
the driving force;
the one that not only
gets themselves going
and doing great things,
but says
we should all do this.
Yauch was
that type of friend.
♪ I don't know ♪
♪ Who does know? ♪
- Yauch, Mike and I have spent
more time with each other
than with our own families.
- It's not like all of it was easy,
or highlight film,
but who gets to work
every day
with their two best friends?
♪ I don't know ♪